Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living.
This episode is brought to you by legal zoom,
which more than 2 million Americans have used to help start their businesses.
Past guests even such as well,
wordpress lead developer,
CEO of Automattic,
Matt Mullenweg now valued at more than a billion dollars,
have used legal zoom to help with their business needs,
specifically in his case to form his company.
But legal zoom isn't just for launching your business.
Their services include everything from helping you to manage changing tax laws,
reviewing contracts,
creating Ndas,
nondisclosure agreements,
important stuff,
handling lease agreements and assisting with really any other legal challenge,
hurdle,
inconvenience that typically takes time and effort away from running your
business.
The best part is that you won't get charged by the hour because legal zoom isn't
a law firm,
so they won't be running the clock up and spinning circles just to raise your
bill.
Instead,
they just ask you to pay one low upfront price for whatever it is that you're
looking to get all the card style.
So visit legal zoom.com and check out their business section for all of their
services and if you want special savings,
that's the terminology in the copy that they suggest.
I don't know what the special savings is folks,
but it's titillating.
If you want special savings,
enter Promo Code Tim Tim at checkout capital t,
lowercase.
I am again,
take a peek legal zoom.com and enter Promo code.
Tim,
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
And my answer is inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole food meals throughout the rest of the
day.
If you want to give athletic Greens to try,
they're offering a free 20 count travel pack for first time users.
I always travel with at least three or four of these.
This represents a $100 value,
so if you by Athletic Greens you get an extra $100 in free product,
so check it up.
Athletic greens.com forward slash Tim again,
that's athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim for your free travel pack with any
purchase.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
This is an experimental episode and my guest so to speak is someone I've known
for quite a long time now.
Sam Harris,
you may know the name,
received a degree in philosophy from Stanford University and a phd in
neuroscience from Ucla.
He's the author of many bestselling books including the interfaith letter to a
Christian nation,
the moral landscape,
freewill lying,
waking up and Islam in the future of tolerance,
a dialogue which he coauthored.
He also hosts the popular podcast waking up with Sam Harris.
You can find him on Twitter at Sam Harris Org,
that's h a r r I s Sam Harris Org and on the web@samharris.org.
But this episode came about because Sam asked me somewhere between six and nine
months ago to be a Beta tester for a new app he was creating and ostensibly it
was a meditation APP.
It's called waking up and you can find it@wakingup.com which I highly recommend.
I anticipated it would be good because Sam is always good and he's one of those
rare humans who very irritably seems to think and speak in finished prose.
He also has a voice,
one of the few voices that can put you into a semi psychedelic state while you
were completely sober.
And if that makes no sense,
it will make sense experientially once you get to the end of this episode.
In any case,
there are some great apps out there for different purposes.
Uh,
among them,
oak made by my friend Kevin Rose for meditation also.
Fantastic.
Sam's approach is a little different and as he puts it in the audio that you're
going to listen to in part he says you do not have to be the best at anything to
be almost uniquely qualified for something.
He is a very unusual combination of experiences and areas of expertise and his
particular approach here is that of a progression and what I like is that
there's a logical progression,
one,
two,
three white belt,
yellow belt,
et Cetera in terms of layering on different types of training for learning,
the skill of meditation and it's really an experience of exploring
consciousness.
He also gets into quite a bit more,
it talks about his experiences with MDA,
his spiritual exploration,
God forbid suit I did there in India,
contact with so called Gurus Dueling masters.
The goal is the path duality versus nonduality and there are a lot of gems
within that you can apply to business,
your personal life,
et Cetera,
because guess what the precursor to all of this is your mind and consciousness,
so learning how to hone the mind and your perceptions is really paramount to
mastering on some level everything else.
If you want to just jump to the meditations and lessons that he presents you can
jump to,
but 47 minutes after he starts and uh,
uh,
those of you who are even more impatient,
I'm going to be publishing a companion episode to this immediately after this
one.
So think of it as simultaneously.
If you go back to where you got this podcast,
you'll find a shorter one of say 10 or 20 minutes.
I'm not sure exactly how long that will take
you through meditations and lessons.
I did one meditation first thing in the morning and one lesson in the late
afternoon to wind down.
That's how I approached it so that you can just hit play and jump immediately
into guided meditations.
And uh,
they will offer different approaches to give you a flavor.
In any case,
the lessons themselves,
we'll jump in to thinking about death,
the mystery of being.
And in the companion episode,
the logic of practice,
this is a somewhat dense episode.
I encourage you to stick with it.
If it's too tough,
if you find yourself wandering in the mind,
which of course you're going to be training in a sense against,
then you can jump to minute 47 after Sam starts for the meditations.
Or you can go to the companion episode.
In either case,
I really suggest checking out waking up.com that is the APP itself.
I have no financial stake,
nothing,
uh,
to gain other than recommending you to a tool that I've found to be incredibly
powerful.
And that is shared by some people.
I also respect greatly who are Beta testers like Dr Peter Attia,
who's also been on the podcast.
So without further ado,
and that was a lot of a do but I think necessary context,
please enjoy this exploration of your own mind and consciousness with Sam
Harris.
Hello,
Tim Ferriss fans.
This is Sam Harris of the waking up podcast and now the waking up course,
which was a app that I just released on Ios and soon to be on android.
And,
uh,
my friend Tim has very generously invited me onto his podcast to preview this
course for you and to speak a little bit about meditation.
And I'm very happy to do that.
First,
a warning.
In addition to just talking about the course and about meditation,
Tim has asked me to preview a few of the guided meditations from the APP.
So parts of this podcast won't make for a very good listening in the car or at
the gym or while multitasking to get value from these sections and to not be
bored by the periods of silence.
You really need to be paying attention.
So if you're not in that situation now,
uh,
you might save this whole podcast for another time.
I'll let you know when I'm dropping them in and how long they are.
So if you insist on listening to this while you are kite surfing or hacking some
government installation or staggering around south by southwest and full ketosis
or whatever it is that the average Tim Ferriss fan does on a day like today,
you will be okay.
Okay.
So I'm going to talk for a while about what I'm attempting to do with this
course and why I've released it as an APP.
Of course,
there,
there are several meditation apps out there and many of them are quite good.
There's calm and headspace and my friends Dan Harris and Joseph Goldstein have
the 10% happier app.
Tim's buddy,
Kevin Rose has the OIC app.
These apps really are quite good and they will definitely teach you how to
meditate and while I cover similar ground in the waking up course,
it's not just a meditation APP.
I'm attempting something else too,
but before I get into the app first let me tell you a little bit about my
background.
For those of you who are not familiar with it,
I got into meditation at the end of my sophomore year in college just when I
turned 20 and this was on the heels of a psychedelic experience that provided a
fairly startling firmware upgrade of my mind.
I've written about psychedelics and supportive and also in fairly cautionary
ways,
especially in my book waking up and actually there's a,
there's a main chapter on that topic that's available both in print and an audio
on my website under the title drugs and the meaning of life.
In fact,
Tim has not only referenced it on this podcast,
but I think the audio is available in one of his earlier podcast and I'll say a
few words about how I view the difference between psychedelics and meditation in
a minute.
Actually I think I should just read you the first few pages of my book waking up
because it gives the full context about how I came to this topic and how I think
about the nature of mind and the role that my experience with psychedelics play
it here and also how I came to the practice of meditation.
So here's how the book begins.
Once participated in a 23 day wilderness program and the mountains of Colorado,
if the purpose of this course was to expose students to dangerous lightning and
half the world's mosquitoes,
it was fulfilled on the first day.
What was,
in essence,
a forced march through hundreds of miles of back country culminated in a ritual
known as the solo where we were finally permitted to rest alone on the outskirts
of a gorgeous Alpine lake.
For three days of fasting and contemplation,
I had just turned 16 and this was my first taste of true solitude since exited
in my mother's womb.
It proved a sufficient provocation after a long nap and a glance at the icy
waters of the lake.
The promising young man I imagined myself to be was quickly cut down by
loneliness and boredom.
I filled the pages of my journal,
not with the insights of a budding naturalist philosopher or mystic,
but with a list of the foods on which I intended to gorge myself.
The incident I return to civilization.
Judging from the state of my consciousness.
At the time,
millions of years of hominid evolution had produced nothing more transcendent
than a craving for a cheeseburger and a chocolate milkshake.
I found the experience of sitting undisturbed for three days and mid pristine
breezes and starlight with nothing to do but contemplate the mystery of my
existence.
Be a source of perfect misery for which I could see not so much as a glimmer of
my own contribution.
My letters home in their plaintiff,
Nis and self pity rivaled any written at Shiloh or globally.
So I was more than a little surprised when several members of our party,
most of whom were a decade older than I described,
their days and nights of solitude in positive,
even transformational terms,
I simply didn't know what to make of their claims to happiness.
How could someone's happiness increase when all the material sources of pleasure
and distraction had been removed at that age?
The nature of my mind did not seem to interest me.
Only my life did.
I was utterly oblivious to how different life would be if the quality of my
mind,
where to change our minds are all we have.
They're all we've ever had and they're all we can offer others.
This might not be obvious,
especially when there are aspects of your life that seem in need of improvement.
When your goals are unrealized or you're struggling to find a career where you
have relationships that need repairing,
but it's the truth.
Every experience you've ever had has been shaped by your mind.
Every relationship is as good or as bad as it is because of the minds involved.
If you are perpetually angry,
depressed,
confused,
and unloving,
or your attention is elsewhere,
it won't matter how successful you become or who is in your life.
You won't enjoy any of it.
Most of us could easily compile a list of goals we want to achieve or personal
problems that need to be solved,
but what is the real significance of every item on such a list?
Everything we want to accomplish to paint the house,
to learn a new language,
to find a better job is something that promises that if done it would allow us
to finally relax and enjoy our lives and the present.
Generally speaking,
this is a false hope.
I'm not denying the importance of achieving one's goals,
maintaining one's health or keeping one's children clothed and fed.
But most of us spend our time seeking happiness and security without
acknowledging the underlying purpose of our search.
Each of us is looking for a path back to the present.
We are trying to find good enough reasons to be satisfied.
Now acknowledging that this is the structure of the game that we're playing
allows us to play it differently.
How we pay attention to the present moment largely determines the character of
our experience and therefore the quality of our lives.
Mystics and contemplative have made this claim for ages,
but a growing body of scientific research now bears it out.
A few years after my first painful encounter with solitude in the winter of 1987
I took the drug three,
four methylenedioxy and methylamphetamine Mtma commonly known as ecstasy.
And my sense of the human mind's potential shifted profoundly.
Although MTMA would become ubiquitous a dance clubs and raves in the 1990s at
the time,
I didn't know anyone of my generation who had tried it.
One evening.
A few months before my 20th birthday,
a close friend and I decided to take the drug.
The setting of our experiment bore little resemblance to the conditions of
Dionysian abandoned under which MDA is now often consumed.
We were alone in a house seated across from each other on opposite ends of the
couch and engaged in quiet conversation as the chemical worked its way into our
heads.
Unlike other drugs with which we were by then familiar marijuana and alcohol
MTMA produced no feeling of distortion in our senses.
Our mind seemed completely clear in the midst of this ordinariness.
However,
I was suddenly struck by the knowledge that I loved my friend.
They shouldn't have surprised me.
He was after all one of my best friends.
However,
at that age,
I was not in the habit of dwelling on how much I love the men in my life.
Now I could feel that I loved him and this feeling had ethical implications that
suddenly seemed as profound as they now seem pedestrian on the page.
I wanted him to be happy.
That conviction came crashing down with such force that something seemed to give
way inside me.
In fact,
the insight appeared to restructure my mind,
my capacity for envy.
For instance,
the sense of being diminished by the happiness or success of another person seem
like a symptom of mental illness that had vanished.
Without a trace,
I could no more who felt envy at that moment than I could have wanted to poke
out my own eyes.
What did I care if my friend was better looking or a better athlete than I was?
If I could have bestowed these gifts on him,
I would have truly wanted him to be happy,
made his happiness my own.
A certain euphoria was creeping into these reflections perhaps,
but the general feeling remained one of absolute sobriety and of moral and
emotional clarity,
unlike any I had ever known.
It would not be too strong to say that I felt sane for the first time in my
life,
and yet the change in my consciousness seemed entirely straightforward.
I was simply talking to my friend about what I don't recall and realize that I
had ceased to be concerned about myself.
I was no longer anxious,
self critical,
guarded by irony in competition,
avoiding embarrassment,
ruminating about the past and future or making any other gesture of thought or
attention that separated me from him.
I was no longer watching myself through another person's eyes and then came the
insight that irrevocably transformed my sense of how good human life could be.
I was feeling boundless love for one of my best friends and I suddenly realized
that if a stranger had walked through the door at that moment,
he or she would have been fully included in this love.
Love was at bottom,
impersonal and deeper than any personal history could justify indeed a
transactional form of love.
I love you because now made no sense at all.
The interesting thing about this final shift in perspective was that it was not
driven by any change in the way I felt.
I was not overwhelmed by a new feeling of love.
The insight had more the character of a geometric proof.
It was as if having glimpse the properties of one set of parallel lines.
I suddenly understood what must be common to them all the moment I could find a
voice with which to speak.
I discovered that this epiphany about the universality of love could be readily
communicated.
My friend got the point at once.
All I had to do was ask him how he would feel in the presence of a total
stranger at that moment and the same door opened in his mind.
It was simply obvious that love,
compassion,
and joy and the joy of others extended without limit.
The experience was not of love growing,
but if it's being no longer obscured,
love was as advertised by mystics and crackpots through the ages,
a state of being.
How have we not seen this before and how could we overlook it ever again?
It would take me many years to put this experience into context.
Until that moment I had viewed organized religion as merely a monument to the
ignorance and superstition of our ancestors,
but I now knew that Jesus,
the Buddha,
loud sue,
and the other saints and sages of history had not all been epileptic
schizophrenia,
x or frauds.
I still considered the world's religions to be mere intellectual ruins
maintained that enormous economic and social costs,
but I now understood that important psychological truths could be found in the
rubble.
Okay,
so that's how I started my book,
Waking Up,
which is a book about the nature of consciousness and how we can understand some
of the life changing experiences people can have experience often described as
mystical or spiritual,
but understand them in a 21st century rational,
scientific context.
Some of you probably know,
I've been a fairly vociferous critic of religion over the years.
I've written several books and participated in many debates,
spelling out the reasons why.
My basic view is that there's a difference between believing things for good
reasons and believing things for bad reasons.
And this is the difference that we all recognize in every area of our lives.
Until the conversation turns to things like God and what happens after death and
the origins of certain books like the Bible and the Koran,
my argument is that we can get what is most profound out of human life without
lying to ourselves or to our children about the nature of reality.
That's not to say that the universe might not be incredibly strange,
whether it's science has everything figured out.
In fact,
the university is incredibly strange and science does not have everything
figured out.
But one thing should be absolutely clear.
The men and women who live 2000 years ago didn't have everything out either and
on many crucial points,
they were ignorant of things that every child learns in school today.
Okay.
Like for instance,
that brains are somehow involved in producing mines.
No one knew this 2000 years ago,
and to deny it today is intellectual irresponsible.
So after I had the experience on Mtma I just described,
I spent the better part of my twenties seeking out a fairly esoteric education.
It wouldn't have been so esoteric in the 60s when many people were dropping out
and going to India with the Beatles,
but it was fairly rare to see someone my age doing this in the late eighties so
most of my friends at the time were 20 years older than I was and I made many
trips to India and they Paul to study with various meditation masters.
I spent around a year and a half or two years on silent retreat,
never for longer than three months at a time.
That was spread out over my twenties I did a couple of three month retreats and
several two month retreats and one month retreats and many shorter ones,
mostly in the context of practicing Vipassana,
otherwise known as mindfulness meditation,
but ultimately practicing Zobe Chan,
which is a Tibetan practice that I'll talk about.
In fact,
I should just read you another section of my book waking up because I spell out
some important distinctions there.
There's a distinction.
Generally speaking between gradual versus sudden notions of realization or
awakening.
And this can seem totally paradoxical to people.
So I'm gonna read you a little bit about this and you'll get more of my
background here.
This from a section in the book titled Gradual Versus Sudden Realization.
We wouldn't attempt to meditate or engage in any other contemplative practice if
we didn't feel that something about our experience needed to be improved.
But here lies one of the central paradoxes of spiritual life because there's
very feeling of dissatisfaction causes us to overlook the Intrinsic Freedom of
consciousness in the present.
As we have seen,
there are good reasons to believe that adopting a practice like meditation can
lead to positive changes in one's life,
but the deepest goal of spirituality is freedom from the illusion of the self.
And to seek such freedom as though or a future state to be attained through
effort is to reinforce the chains of one's apparent bondage in each moment.
Traditionally,
there have been two solutions to this paradox.
One is to simply ignore it and to adopt various techniques of meditation and the
hope that a breakthrough will occur.
Some people appear to succeed at this,
but many fail.
It is true that good things often happen.
In the meantime,
we can become happier and more concentrated,
but we can also despair of the whole project.
The words of the sages may begin to sound like empty promises and we're left
hoping for transcendent experiences that never arrive or prove merely temporary.
The ultimate wisdom of enlightenment,
whatever it is,
cannot be a matter of having fleeting experiences.
The goal of meditation is to uncover a form of wellbeing that is inherent to the
nature of our minds.
It must therefore be available in the context of ordinary sights,
sounds,
sensations,
and even thoughts.
Peak experiences are fine,
but real freedom must be coincident with normal waking life.
And as a sidebar to this,
this now me speaking off book,
this is one of the crucial distinctions between meditation and Psychedelics as
tools.
It's very easy to draw the lesson from psychedelic experiences,
however useful that freedom somehow lives in radically transforming the contents
and character of consciousness.
Whereas the goal of meditation is to recognize that there is something about
ordinary consciousness,
the very awareness in you that is experiencing the sound of my voice in this
moment.
There's already radically free of self.
It's already open.
It's already undefined.
Consciousness never is truly confined by its contents.
And so while psychedelics have been very useful for me and many others,
the center of the Bullseye for me is something that is actually coincident with
normal waking consciousness where I'm at precisely the kind of consciousness
that it could allow you to safely drive a car,
right?
Which if you've ever taken acid or mushrooms is not where one tends to be
pitched on those drugs.
So back to the text.
The other traditional response to the paradox of spiritual seeking is to fully
acknowledge it and concede that all efforts are doomed because the urge to
attain self transcendence or any other mystical experience is a symptom of the
very disease we want to cure.
There is nothing to do but give up the search.
These paths may appear antithetical and they are often presented as such.
The path of gradual ascent is typical of Teravata,
Buddhism and most other approaches to meditation in the Indian tradition and
gradualism is the natural starting point for any search,
spiritual or otherwise.
Such goal oriented modes of practice have the virtue of being easily taught
because a person can begin them without having had any fundamental insight into
the nature of consciousness or the illusory ness of the self.
He need only adopt new patterns of attention,
thought and behavior and the path will unfold before him.
By contrast,
the path of sudden realization can appear impossibly steep is often described as
quote non-dualistic because it refuses to validate the point of view from which
one would meditate or practice any other spiritual discipline.
Consciousness is already free of that remotely resembles a self and there is
nothing you can do as an illusionary ego to realize this.
Such a perspective can be found in the Indian tradition of Advaita Vedanta and
in a few schools of Buddhism.
Those who begin to practice in the spirit of gradualism often assume that the
goal of self transcendence is far away and they may spend years overlooking the
very freedom they yearn to realize.
The liability of this approach became clear to me when I studied under the
Burmese meditation master side out who Pandita.
I sat through several retreats with open data each a month or two in length.
These are treats were based on the monastic discipline of Teravata in Buddhism.
We did not eat after noon and we're encouraged to sleep no more than four hours
each night.
Outwardly,
the goal was to engage in 18 hours of formal meditation each day.
Inwardly it was to follow the stages of insight laid out in Buda,
ghosts as fifth century treatise.
The vesuvio Maga and elaborated in the writings of [inaudible] has own legendary
teacher Mahasi Sayadaw.
The logic of this practice is explicitly goal oriented according to this view,
one practices mindfulness not because the intrinsic freedom of consciousness can
be fully realized in the present,
but because being mindful is a means for attaining and experience often
described as quote cessation which is thought to decisively uproot the illusion
of the self along with other mental afflictions depending on one stage of
practice,
cessation is believed to be a direct insight into an unconditioned reality.
In Pauley,
this is called Nibhaana in Sanskrit and nirvana that lies behind all manifest
phenomena.
This conception of the path to enlightenment is open to several criticisms.
The first is that it is misleading with respect to what can be realized in the
present moment in a state of ordinary awareness.
Thus,
it encourages confusion at the outset regarding the nature of the problem one is
trying to solve.
It is true,
however,
that striving toward the distant goal of enlightenment as well as the nearer a
goal of cessation can lead one to practice with an intensity that might
otherwise be difficult to achieve.
I never made more effort than I did when practicing under group on data,
but most of this effort arose from the very illusion of bondage to the self that
I was seeking to overcome.
The model of this practice is that one must climb the mountain so that freedom
can be found at the top but the self is already an illusion and that truth can
be glimpsed directly at the mountains base or anywhere else along the path.
One can then return to this insight again and again as one sole method of
meditation thereby arrive in at the goal in each moment of actual practice.
This isn't merely a matter of choosing to think differently about the
significance of mindfulness.
It is a difference in what one is able to be mindful of dualistic mindfulness,
paying attention to the breath for instance generally proceeds on the basis of
an illusion.
One feels that one is a subject,
a locus of consciousness inside the head that can strategically pay attention to
the breath or to some other object of awareness because of all the good that it
will do.
This is gradualism inaction and yet from a non dualistic point of view,
one could just as well be mindful of selflessness directly to do this.
However,
one must recognize that this is how consciousness is and such an insight can be
difficult to achieve.
However,
it does not require the meditative attainment of cessation.
Another problem with the goal of cessation is it most traditions of Buddhism do
not share it,
and yet they produce long lineages of contemplative masters,
many of whom have spent decades doing nothing but meditating on the nature of
consciousness.
If freedom is possible,
there must be some mode of ordinary consciousness in which it can be expressed.
Why not realize this frame of mind directly?
Nevertheless,
I spent several years deeply preoccupied with reaching the goal of cessation and
at least one year of that time was spent on silent retreat.
Although I had many interesting experiences,
none seem to fit the specific requirements of this path.
There were periods during which all thoughts subsided and any sense of having a
body disappeared.
What remained was a blissful expanse of conscious piece that had no reference
point in any of the usual sensory channels.
Many scientists and philosophers believe that consciousness is always tied to
one of the five senses,
that the idea of pure consciousness,
apart from seeing,
hearing,
smelling,
tasting,
and touching is a category error and a spiritual fantasy.
I am confident that they are mistaken,
but cessation never arrived given my gradualist views at that point.
This became very frustrated.
Most of my time on retreat was extremely pleasant,
but it seemed to me that I had been merely given the tools with which to
contemplate the evidence of my non enlightenment.
My practice has become a vigil,
a method of waiting,
however patiently for a future reward.
The pendulum swung when I met an Indian teacher named Hwl Pooja called Puente GG
or papa g by his students who Intergy was a disciple of Ramana Maharshi,
arguably the most widely revered Indian sage of the 20th century Ramona's own
awakening and had been quite unusual because he'd had no apparent spiritual
interest or contact with a teacher.
As a boy of 16 living in a middle class family of south Indian Brahmins,
he spontaneously became a spiritual add depth while sitting alone in his uncle
study,
Ramana suddenly became paralyzed by fear of death.
He laid down on the floor,
convinced that he would soon die,
but rather than remaining terrified,
he decided to locate the self that was about to disappear.
He focused on the feeling of I a process.
He later called self inquiry and found it to be absent from the field of
consciousness.
Ramana the person didn't die that day,
but he claimed that the feeling of being a separate self never darkened his
consciousness again after fruitlessly attempting to behave like the ordinary boy
he had once been Ramana left home and traveled to tear of anomaly and ancient
pilgrimage site for followers of Shiva.
He spent the rest of his life.
They're in proximity to the mountain Arunachala with which he claimed to have a
mystical connection.
In the early years after his awakening,
Ramana seem to lose his ability to speak and he was said to grow,
so absorbed in his experience of transfigured consciousness that he remained
motionless for days at a time.
His body grew weak,
develop sores and had to be tended by the few locals who had taken an interest
in him.
After a decade of silence around 1906 Ramana began to conduct dialogues about
the nature of consciousness until the end of his life,
a steady stream of students came to study with him.
These are the sorts of things he was apt to say.
These are quotes from Ramana Maharshi.
The mind is a bundle of thoughts.
The thoughts arise because there's the thinker.
The thinker is the ego.
The Ego if saw it will automatically vanish.
Here's another quote.
Reality is simply the loss of the ego destroy the ego by seeking this identity,
because ego is no entity,
it will automatically vanish and reality will shine forth by itself.
This is the direct method,
whereas all other methods are done only retaining the ego.
No sadness.
Spiritual practices are necessary for engaging in this quest.
And finally,
here's one more quote.
There is no mystery greater than this.
That being reality,
we seek to gain reality.
We think that there's something hiding our reality and then it must be destroyed
before the reality is gained.
It is ridiculous.
A day will dawn when you will laugh at your past efforts that which will be on
the day you laugh is also here and now back to my text.
Any attempt to make sense of such teachings in third person scientific terms
quickly produces monstrosities from the point of view of psychological science.
For instance,
the mind is not just a quote bundle of thoughts and in what sense can reality be
quote simply the loss of the ego.
Does this reality include quasars and Hanta virus?
But these are the kinds of quibbles that will cause one to Miss Ramana's point.
While the philosophy of Advita and that's the US,
the word for non-dualism in Sanskrit.
While the philosophy of Advita and Ramana's own words may tend to support a
metaphysical reading of teachings of this kind.
Their validity is not metaphysical,
rather it is experiential.
The whole of Advanta reduces to a series of very simple and testable assertions.
Consciousness is the prior condition of every experience.
The self or ego is an illusory appearance within it.
Look closely for what you are calling I and the feeling of being a separate self
will disappear.
What remains as a matter of experience is a field of consciousness,
free,
undivided,
and intrinsically uncontaminated by as ever changing contents.
These are the simple truths that Puente Jiji taught.
In fact,
he was even more uncompromising than his guru in his nonduality,
whereas Ramana would often can see the utility of certain dualistic practices.
Puente judge,
he never gave an inch.
The effect was intoxicating,
especially to those of us who had spent years practicing meditation punted.
She was also given to spontaneous bounce of weeping and laughter,
both apparently from sheer joy.
The man did not hide his light under a Bushel.
When I first met him.
He had not yet been discovered by the throngs of Western devotees who would soon
turn his tiny house and luck now into a spiritual circus like his teacher,
Ramana Puente g claim to be perfectly free from the illusion of the self.
And by all appearances he was,
and like Ramana and every other Indian guru Puente,
she would occasionally say something deeply unscientific on the whole.
However,
his teaching was remarkably free from Hindu religiosity or unwarranted
assertions about the nature of the cosmos.
He appeared to simply speak from experience about the nature of experience
itself.
Puente,
druggies influence on me was profound,
especially because it came as a corrective to all the strenuous and unsatisfying
efforts I'd been making in meditation up until that point.
But the dangers inherent to his approach soon became obvious.
The all or nothing quality of Puente or gs teaching obliged him to acknowledge
the full enlightenment of any person who was grandiose or manic enough to claim
it.
Thus I repeatedly witnessed fellow students declare their complete and undying
freedom,
all the while appearing quite ordinary or worse in certain cases.
These people had clearly had some sort of breakthrough,
but poons,
Geez,
insistence upon the finality of every legitimate insight led many of them to
delude themselves about their spiritual attainments.
Some left India and became gurus.
From what I could tell,
punchy g gave everyone his blessing to spread his teachings in this way.
He wants suggested that I do it,
and yet it was clear to me that I was not qualified to be anyone's guru.
Nearly 20 years have passed and I'm still not,
of course,
from Puente Judge's point of view,
this is an illusion,
and yet there simply is a difference between a person like myself who is
generally distracted by thought and one who isn't and cannot be.
I don't know where to place Puente or g on this continuum of wisdom,
but he appeared to be a lot farther along than his students.
Whether Punto she was capable of seeing the difference between himself and other
people.
I do not know,
but his insistence that no difference existed began to seem either dogmatic or
delusional.
On one occasion,
events conspired to perfectly aluminate the flaw in Puente or gs teaching.
A small group of experienced practitioners among us,
several teachers of meditation had organized a trip to India,
Nepal to spend 10 days with Puente Gigi in lock now followed by 10 days in
Katmandu to receive teachings on the Tibetan Buddhist practice of Xojane as it
happened during our time and luck now,
a woman from Switzerland became quote,
enlightened in Puente druggies presence for the better part of a week.
She was celebrated as something akin to the next Buddha who hindered you
repeatedly put her forward as evidence of how fully the truth could be realized
without making any effort at all in meditation.
And we had the pleasure of seeing this woman sit beside Puente and g on a raised
platform expounding upon how blissful at now was in her corner of the universe.
She was in fact radiantly happy and it was by no means clear that Puente Gigi
had made a mistake and recognizing her.
She would say things like there is nothing but consciousness and there is no
difference between it and reality itself coming from such a nice guile,
this person,
there was little reason to doubt the profundity of her experience when it came
time for our group to leave India for Nepal.
This woman asked if she could join us because she was such good company.
We encouraged her to come along a few of us.
We're also curious to see how her realization would appear in another context
and so it came to pass that a woman who is enlightenment had just been confirmed
by one of the greatest living exponent of Advita was in the room when we
received our first teachings from Tuk,
Oregon [inaudible] Jay,
who was generally thought to be one of the greatest living zone 10 masters of
all the Buddhist teachings,
those of Zohak Gen most closely resemble the teachings of Advita.
The two traditions seek to provoke the same insight into the non duality of
consciousness,
but generally speaking only zog Jen makes it absolutely clear that one was
practice this insight to the point of stability and that one can do so without
succumbing to the dualistic striving that haunts most other paths.
At a certain point.
In our discussions with Tuco Oregon,
our Swiss prodigy declared her boundless freedom in terms similar to those had
used to such great effect with punch g.
After a few highly amusing exchanges during which we watched took,
Oregon's struggled to understand what our translator was telling him.
He gave a short laugh and look the woman over with renewed interest.
How long has it been since you were last lost in thought he asked.
I haven't had any thoughts for over a week.
The woman replied,
took Oregon smiled a week.
Yes,
no thoughts.
No.
My mind is completely still.
It's just pure consciousness.
That's very interesting.
Okay,
so this is what's going to happen now.
We're all going to wait for you to have your next thought.
There's no hurry.
We're all very patient people.
We're just going to sit here and wait,
so please tell us.
When you notice a thought arise in your mind,
it is difficult to convey what a brilliant and subtle intervention this was.
It may have been the most inspired moment of teaching I have ever witnessed.
After a few moments,
a look of doubt appeared on our friend's face.
Okay,
wait a minute.
Oh,
that could have been a thought there.
Okay.
Over the next 30 seconds,
we watched this woman's enlightenment completely unravel.
It became clear that she had been merely thinking about how expansive her
experience of consciousness had become,
how it was perfectly free of thought,
immaculate,
just like space without noticing that she was thinking incessantly.
She had been telling herself the story of her enlightenment and she had been
getting away with it because she happened to be an extraordinarily happy person
for whom everything was going well.
For the time being.
This was the danger of nondual teachings of the sort that Poon Gigi was handing
out to all comers.
It was easy to delude oneself into thinking that one had achieved a permanent
break through especially because he insisted that all breakthroughs must be
permanent.
What the Xojane teachings made clear,
however,
is that thinking about what is beyond thought is still thinking and a glimpse of
selflessness is generally only the beginning of a process that must reach
fruition.
Being able to stand perfectly free of the feeling of self is the start of one
spiritual journey,
not attend.
I think I'll read one more section here cause this,
he'll give you more context for how I think about meditation.
So next section here at titled Chen taking the goal is the path took Oregon
Rimpoche.
Jay lived in a hermitage on the southern slope of Shiva Pori mountain
overlooking Katmandu Valley.
He spent more than 20 years of his life on formal retreat and was deservedly
famous for the clarity with which he gave the quote,
pointing out instruction of Xojane,
a formal initiation in which a teacher is seeks to impart the experience of self
transcendence directly to a student.
I received this teaching from several soak and masters,
but I never met anyone who spoke about the nature of consciousness as precisely
as to Corrigan in the last five years of his life.
I made several trips to Nepal to study with him.
The practice of Zog Gen requires that one be able to experience the intrinsic
selflessness of awareness in every moment.
That is when one is not otherwise distracted by thought,
which is to say the,
for a Xojane meditator,
mindfulness must be synonymous with dispelling the illusion of the self rather
than teach a technique of meditation such as paying close attention to one's
breathing as ocean master must precipitate an insight on the basis of which a
student can thereafter practice a form of awareness.
The dependent term is Rick Ba that is unencumbered by subject object dualism.
Thus it is often said in Soak Chen,
that one quote takes the goal as the path because the freedom from self that one
might otherwise seek is the very thing that one practices the goal of Xojane if
one can call it.
Such is to grow increasingly familiar with this way of being.
In the world.
In my experience,
some soaked and masters are better teachers than others.
I've been in the presence of several of the most revered Tibetan lamas of our
time while they were extensively teaching Xojane,
and most of them simply describe this view of consciousness without giving clear
instructions on how to glimpse it.
The genius of Choke Oregon was that he could point out the nature of mind with
the precision and matter of factness,
of teaching a person how to thread a needle and could get an ordinary meditator
like me to recognize that consciousness is intrinsically free of self.
There might be some initial struggle and uncertainty depending on the student,
but once the truth of nonduality had been glimpsed,
it became obvious that it was always available and there was never any doubt
about how to see it.
Again.
I came to Tukul,
Oregon yearning for the experience of self transcendence and in a few minutes he
showed me that I had no self to transcend.
In my view,
there's nothing supernatural or even mysterious about this transmission of
wisdom from master to disciple took Oregon's effect on me came purely from the
clarity of his teaching as it is with any challenging endeavor.
The difference between being utterly misled by false information being nudged in
the general direction and being precisely guided by an expert is difficult to
overstate the direct perception of the optic blindspot provides a useful
analogy.
Imagine that perceiving the blind spot will completely transform a person's
life.
Next,
imagine that whole religions such as Judaism,
Christianity,
and Islam are predicated on the denial of the blind spots existence.
Let us say that their central doctrines assert the perfect uniformity of the
visual field.
Perhaps other traditions acknowledged the blind spot,
but purely and poetical terms without giving any clear indication of how to
recognize it.
A fuel in you just may actually teach techniques whereby one can see the blind
spot for oneself,
but only gradually after months and years of effort and even then one glimpses
of it will seem more a matter of luck than anything else in a more esoteric
traditions.
Still a quote.
Blindspot master gives the quote pointing out instruction,
but without much precision.
Perhaps he tells you to close one eye for reasons that are never made explicit
and then says that the spot you seek is right on the surface of your vision.
No doubt some people succeed in discovering the blind spot under these
conditions,
but the teacher is certainly could be clearer than this.
How much clearer if two local Oregon had been pointing out the blind spot,
he would have produced a figure like the one below and given these instructions.
And then I have the classic image you would use to glimpse your own blind spot
of a fixation cross on one side and a large dot on the other.
And then I give the instructions here.
I'll just read them through it and remind you about how clear this could be.
One,
hold this figure in front of you at arms length to close your left eye and stare
at the cross with your right three gradually move the page closer to your face
while keeping your gaze fixed on the cross for notice when the dot on the right
disappears.
Five.
Once you find your blind spot continue to experiment with this figure by moving
the page back and forth until any possibility of doubt about the existence of
the blind spot has disappeared,
is considered bad form and most spiritual circles,
especially among Buddhists,
to make claims about one's own realization.
However,
I think this taboo comes at a high price because it allows people to remain
confused about how to practice.
So I will describe my experience plainly before meeting to Corrigan,
I had spent at least a year practicing of Apos,
non silent retreats.
The experience of self transcendence was not entirely unknown to me.
I could remember moments when the distance between the observer and the observed
had seemed to vanish,
but I viewed these experiences as being dependent on conditions of extreme
mental concentration.
Consequently,
I had thought that they were unavailable in more ordinary moments outside
intensive retreat.
But after a few minutes took,
Oregon's simply handed me the ability to cut through the illusion of the self
directly,
even in ordinary states of consciousness.
This instruction was without question the most important thing I've ever been
explicitly taught by another human being.
It has given me a way to escape the usual tides of psychological suffering,
fear,
anger,
shame in an instant that my level of practice,
this freedom lasts only a few moments,
but these moments can be repeated and they can grow in duration,
punctuating,
ordinary experience in this way,
it makes all the difference.
In fact,
when I pay attention,
it is impossible for me to feel like a self at all.
The implied center of cognition and emotion simply falls away and it is obvious
that consciousness has never truly confined by what it knows that which is aware
of sadness is not sad,
that which is aware of fear is not fearful.
The moment I am lost in thought,
however,
I'm as confused as anyone else given this change in my perception of the world.
I understand the attractions of traditional spirituality.
I also recognize the needless confusion and harm that inevitably arise from the
doctrines of faith based religion.
I did not have to believe anything irrational about the universe or about my
place within it to learn the practice of Xojane.
I didn't have to accept Tibetan Buddhist beliefs about Karma and rebirth or
imagine that two cool Oregon or the other meditation masters I met possessed
magic powers and whatever the traditional liabilities of a guru devotee
relationship.
I know from direct experience that is possible to meet a teacher who can deliver
the goods.
Okay,
so that's the end of my reading.
So that's how I come to the practice of meditation.
And after I spent the decades of my twenties largely focused on meditation as
well as reading the relevant eastern and Western philosophy,
I decided to go back to school because I was writing nonfiction about the nature
of the mind.
Happily I had dropped out of Stanford University where you can never really drop
out.
I think Stanford is one of the few schools in the United States that has a
policy of never making you reapply.
So it just showed up like some rip Van Winkle character after 11 years away and
finished my degree in philosophy and then went on to do a phd in neuroscience at
Ucla.
So I bring a philosophical and scientific and secular perspective meditation.
Ultimately I think we should all be practicing non dual mindfulness without
believing any bullshit that is a human future worth wanting.
And that's what I'm attempting to equip people to do in the waking up course in
producing the,
and of course I'm attempting to do something that I'm especially qualified to
do,
man.
I don't consider myself the best at any one thing,
but you don't have to be the best at anything to be almost uniquely qualified
for something.
The weekend of course is in part a meditation course.
So obviously there are a guided meditation compre continually adding to those as
time goes on.
I would say that even if you're an experienced meditator,
using guided meditations can be extremely helpful.
And this is one of the things that's unique about audio.
You can't do this with a book.
There's no alternative to having an actual voice remind you that you're supposed
to be paying attention,
and I find guided meditation is extremely helpful and I've been meditating for
now nearly 30 years.
In addition to the guided meditations,
there's also an expanding curriculum of short talks on a variety of topics I
call these talks lessons,
some explained concepts that are directly relevant to meditation.
Others are more like philosophical interventions or have you reflect on a
specific topic for a few minutes.
Sometimes starting with a scientific finding or quotation that inspires a
particular line of thought.
So here I'd like to give you a taste of the course.
I'll start with one of the early meditations,
very much designed for someone new to the practice of mindfulness.
So if you're not on board already,
this is the part of the podcast that really will bore you to tears if you're
working out of the gym or commuting.
But if you're in a spot where you can meditate,
here's the first 10 minute meditation.
Okay?
Once again,
take a seat either in a chair or cross legged on a cushion.
Okay.
It's good to sit as comfortably as you can
and it's usually best to be sitting as straight as you can.
Now close your eyes
and become aware of the sensations of sitting.
Okay.
Feel your arms at your sides
and perhaps take a few deep breaths.
Just allow gravity to settle you into your seat
now as you did yesterday,
they'd come aware of the sensations of breathing.
Yeah,
notice where you feel the breath most clearly,
either at the tip of the nose or the rising and falling of your abdomen or
chest.
It doesn't matter where you pay attention to the breath
and you can change your focus from session to session if you like,
but for the moment,
just pick one spot and focus there.
There's nothing especially significant about the breath,
but it's something you always have with you
and it's as good as any other sense.
Object as a basis for training your powers of attention.
Eventually the practice will incorporate everything that arises in
consciousness.
Just feel the mirror sensations of breathing from the beginning of the
inhalation
to the pause between breaths
and follow the exhalation to the end.
Trying to cover the breath with your awareness.
And once again,
there's no need to control your breathing.
Just let it come however it comes.
What we're doing here is sharpening the only tool you really have your mind.
This is what you take with you in any situation in life.
This is what determines how you respond to emotional stress and physical pain
and every other difficulty you encounter.
This is the basis for every decision you make and every interaction you have
with other people.
Okay?
And as you begin to observe it,
you'll notice perhaps with growing amazement
that your mind is totally out of control.
And as you try to pay attention to the breath,
you'll begin to notice that the primary obstacle to your paying attention is
thinking
thoughts continually arise.
And you forget that you were even trying to meditate at all.
And this happens over the course of mere seconds.
Just try to count the next 10 breaths without getting distracted.
You can silently in your mind count one on the inhalation and one again on the
exhalation and then to see if you can get to 10
unless you have a lot of concentration,
you probably were unable to tell how precarious here awareness of the breath
actually was,
how your attention was being buffeted on all sides by discursive thought.
Now the goal isn't to stop your thoughts or to suppress any emotion that might
arise along with them.
It is rather to notice these mental events clearly and to experience them fully
or more fully.
In fact,
okay,
to recognize them as appearances and consciousness the moment they arise,
but that is generally a very difficult thing to do in the beginning.
So for the time being,
the moment you discover that you're thinking,
just observe it and come back to the breath.
In this final minute of the meditation,
just start again.
Just feel the next breath as it comes.
Okay.
Well just take a moment to take stock of how you're feeling.
Yeah.
Whether you're tired or restless or calm.
Okay.
Whether your experience was pleasant or unpleasant isn't really the point.
What you're learning here is a new skill.
Okay.
And unless you're coming to this course already knowing how to meditate,
you can't expect to be able to do it well in the beginning.
Yeah.
And is the practice develops over the next days and weeks,
you'll see that you do less,
not more than you normally do.
You're not adding an artifice to your experience in the present moment.
Rather,
you're simply becoming less distracted.
The purpose of meditation is to discover what's your mind is like when you're no
longer perpetually identified with the contents of your thoughts.
And to make progress,
you simply need to be willing to begin again.
Okay.
So that's what an early guided meditation sounds like.
Now,
I'll give you a lesson and these are,
again,
these are short talks on many different topics.
Here's one on the topic of death.
Well,
today's topic is a topic we all think about while doing our best not to think
about it.
The topic is death,
okay?
And how we think about death changes depending on whether we're thinking about
dying ourselves or about losing the people we love.
But whichever side of the coin we take here.
Okay.
Death is really an ever present reality for us and it is.
So whether we're thinking about it or not,
it's always announcing itself in the background on the news,
in the stories we hear about the lives of others.
Okay.
In our concerns about our own health.
In the attention we pay when crossing the street.
Okay.
If you observe yourself closely,
you'll see that you spend a fair amount of energy each day trying not to die.
Yeah.
And has long been noted by philosophers and contemplative and poets.
Death makes a mockery of almost everything else we spend our lives doing.
Okay.
Just take a moment to reflect on how you've spent your day so far.
The kinds of things that captured your attention,
the things that you've been genuinely worried about.
Yeah.
Think of the last argument you had with your spouse.
Think of the last hour you spent on social media.
Over the last few days,
I've been spending an inordinate amount of time trying to find a new font for my
podcast.
This is literally absorbed hours of my time.
So if you had stopped me at any point in the last 48 hours and asked me what I'm
up to,
what really concerns me,
what deep problem I'm attempting to solve the solution in which seems most
likely to bring order to the chaos in my corner of the universe.
The honest answer would have been,
I'm looking for a font
now.
I'm not saying that everything we do has to be profound in every moment.
I mean sometimes you just have to find a font,
but contemplating the brevity of life,
bring some perspective to how we use our attention.
It's not so much what we pay attention to.
It's the quality of attention is how we feel while doing it.
If you need to spend the next hour looking for a font,
you might as well enjoy it because it's truth is none of us know how much time
we have in this life and taking that fact to heart brings a kind of moral and
emotional clarity and energy to the present,
or at least it can and it can bring a resolve to not suffer over stupid things.
Can we take something like road rage?
This is probably the quintessential example of misspent energy.
You're behind the wheel of your car and somebody does something erratic or
they're probably just driving more slowly than you want and you find yourself
getting angry.
Now,
I would submit to you that that kind of thing is impossible.
If you're being mindful of the shortness of life,
if you're aware that you are going to die and that the other person is going to
die and that you're both going to lose everyone you love and you don't know when
you've got this moment of life,
this beautiful moment,
this moment where your consciousness is bright,
whereas it's not dimmed by morphine in the hospital on your last day among the
living
and the sun is out or it's raining,
both are beautiful and your spouse is alive and your children are alive and
you're driving
and you're not in some failed state where civilians are being rounded up and
murdered by the thousands.
You're just running an errand and that person in front of you who you will never
meet,
whose hopes and sorrows you know nothing about,
but which,
if you could know them,
you would recognize or impressively similar to your own,
is just driving slow.
This is your life,
the only one you've got,
and you will never get this moment back again.
And you don't know how many more moments you have.
No matter how many times you do something,
there will come a day when you do it for the last time.
You've had a thousand chances to tell the people closest to you that you love
them in a way that they feel it and in a way that you feel it and you've missed
most of them
and you don't know how many more you're going to get.
You've got this next interaction with another human being to make the world a
marginally better place.
You've got this one opportunity to fall in love with existence,
so why not relax and enjoy your life really relaxed,
even in the midst of struggle,
even while doing hard work,
even under uncertainty.
You are in a game right now and you can't see the clock,
so you don't know how much time you have left,
and yet you're free to make the game as interesting as possible.
You can even change the rules.
You can discover new games that no one has thought of yet.
You can make games that used to be impossible suddenly possible and get others
to play them with you.
You can literally build a rocket to go to Mars so that you can start a colony
there.
I actually know people who will spend some part of today doing that,
but whatever you do,
however seemingly ordinary you can feel the preciousness of life,
that an awareness of death is the doorway into that way of being in the world.
Okay,
here's a lesson titled the mystery of being
of all the solar systems in this universe that might sustain complex life.
We find ourselves in this one.
He took billions of years of evolution on this earth to produce the people we
now are.
Our brains and bodies have evolved through millions of generations reaching back
to Creekers,
totally unlike us to animals.
So strange that we wouldn't even want them as pets and finally to single celled
organisms for ages.
The world got on without us,
but now we're here and among all the possible people that could exist,
we are among the tiny minority that actually do and have all the periods in
human history where we might have appeared.
We live in this one,
arguably the first in which it was possible to understand our circumstance in a
truly universal sense.
For the first time,
a person's view of the world need not be dictated by the mere location of his
birth or the religion of his parents for the first time.
The barriers of language and geography have totally fallen away.
At this moment.
You have instantaneous access to more information than even the greatest scholar
a world leader did a generation ago.
And yet on some level we can front the same mystery of our existence that
Socrates,
where the Buddha faced.
The fact that you are at you,
the fact that you exist in this moment,
he is a miracle of sorts.
There's something fundamentally inexplicable about it.
There's no amount of knowledge that seems adequate to dispel the mystery of our
appearance here and whatever,
you know,
whatever you believe,
whatever you have done or hope to do,
you have this moment of conscious life to contemplate.
You have this minute,
this hour,
this day,
and it will never come again.
Yeah.
So I want to talk for a few minutes about the intrinsic mystery of this
circumstance.
It really is the mystery of being in science and philosophy.
We often claim that we're in the business of getting rid of mysteries and there
is of course a sense in which that's true.
If we don't know why people are getting sick,
for instance,
and we discovered the virus that's causing it,
well then the mystery has been solved.
But there's another sense in which mystery never recedes and if you pay
attention,
you can see that it's an ever present fact of even the most well understood
phenomena.
The philosopher Bertrand Russell described her most rudimentary knowledge of the
world as knowledge by acquaintance.
For instance,
the color of a table standing before you,
and here's a quote,
the particular shade of color that I'm seeing may have many things said about
it.
I might say that it is brown that is rather dark and so on,
but such statements do they make me know truths about the color do not make me
know the color itself any better than I did before so far as concerns,
the knowledge of the color itself as opposed to knowledge of truth about it.
I know the color perfectly and completely when I see it and no further knowledge
of it is even theoretically possible.
Thus the sense data which make up the appearance of my table are things with
which I have acquaintance and things immediately known to me just as they are
and quote.
Now,
what Russell seems to overlook here is that this basic knowledge to which no
knowledge can even be theoretically added is a place where we uncover an
intrinsic limit to understanding when we consider any facet of experience,
in this case,
a vision of color.
If we can then stem the tide of our thoughts long enough to merely observe it as
it is,
the fact that we're in total ignorance of what it is can become obvious.
I mean,
what is the color blue?
Not as a function of wavelengths of light or neurophysiology,
but as it has directly perceived.
We're really left with nothing to say,
but that it's blue,
which of course does nothing to clarify things.
In fact,
it's not even blue,
which is just a word.
It's a noise we're making.
Well,
what we see before us is whatever it ineffably is
focusing on this distance between concepts and experience is a means of sneaking
up on a truth is generally described in Buddhism as the truth of emptiness.
The idea that no thing has intrinsic independent existence in the way that it
seems now.
There are many ways to come at this insight into emptiness and frankly this line
of inquiry maybe too steep for some of you at this point,
so I encourage you to return to it after you have more experience in the
practice of meditation,
but it is worth reflecting on even in the beginning.
The moment we suspend the conceptual associations we have with a given object or
perception or knowledge about it,
our direct experience of it can grade into this experience of just pure mystery.
We're left with this wordless intuition of consciousness and its contents about
which nothing more really can be said.
Right?
Right now,
as you listen to me speak,
pay careful attention to the process of listening,
the feeling of sitting in your chair.
Look closely at everything around you.
I'd like to suggest that while you know many things about the present moment,
you do not know what anything in itself is.
Now look at your hand.
What is it?
We can define this part of your body in language.
You can call it hand.
You can consider the fact that it's made of bone and muscle and threaded with
blood vessels and nerves,
but this is all a description about the object that you're now looking at.
If you simply look at your hand and ask yourself what is it you might realize in
a moment of rare openmindedness that it is an absolute mystery.
It is in fact as mysterious and appearance as any you could ever hope to find.
Now there are scientific arguments that can be a raid against the mysteriousness
of any object.
We can point to the fact that the atoms in your hand,
we're born billions of years ago in the belly of a star and in fact some of
these atoms may have inhabited several stars in succession is even possible that
some atoms that were once in the bond is of historical figures like Churchill or
Cleopatra or now in you.
In fact,
it might be descriptively true to implicate the entire universe in your hand or
in any objects being what it is,
but no such litany of concepts or connections can account for the mystery that
looms whenever you just look at something closely,
anything,
however commonplace,
and realize that while you might have volumes of knowledge about it,
you don't have the slightest understanding of what it is in itself.
Now,
others have noticed this fact,
Walter Benjamin,
the chairman,
literary critic,
stumbled upon this mystery and Marcee after smoking hashish for the first time.
He distilled it in the phrase how things with Stan,
the gays
and all things really do with Stan the gays.
We confront the mystery of being in every moment,
but we don't notice it because there's mystery is tiled over with concepts.
Okay?
Now,
meditation isn't about understanding things.
Conceptually.
It's the ability to experience things more clearly prior to concepts.
It is the knowledge by acquaintance that Russell spoke of here taken to the
ultimate degree and the more you practice it,
you'll find that it really is a new form of intelligence.
It leads to another way of being in the world and one that can allow for a kind
of psychological freedom than a continuous entanglement with concepts.
It doesn't.
There's a famous parable from the Buddha meant to get at this difference.
A man has struck in the chest with a poison arrow and a surgeon Russia's to
assigned to begin the work of saving his life.
But the man resists the first wants to know the name of the Fletcher,
who fashioned the arrows shaft and the type of wood from which it was cut and
the motive of the man who shot it and the name of the horse upon what she road
and a thousand other things that have no bearing at all upon his present
suffering or ultimate survival.
So this man needs to get his priorities straight.
His commitment to thinking about the world results from a basic misunderstanding
of his predicament.
And then we may be only dimly aware of it,
we to have problems that will not be solved by more thinking.
Finally,
here's a 12 minute guided meditation that comes a little later in the course.
Okay?
As you get comfortable in your seat,
he might keep your eyes open for the beginning of this session
and take a few deep breaths
and just let yourself settle into the feeling of resting in space.
And as you gaze in front of you,
just let your gaze be as wide as possible.
No need to focus on anything in particular.
Just stare into space
with a soft eyes,
feeling the breath come and go.
Listen to the sounds in the room.
Okay.
Horizon and passing away.
And as you stare into your visual field,
take a moment to look for what is looking.
See if you can look back,
whether your attention at the one who has seen,
this may sound paradoxical,
but see what happens.
The moment you look,
it was a teacher named Douglas Hardin who wrote a book titled on Having No head
and the exercise he recommended to his students was to gaze at whatever is
before you and look for your own head.
Notice that your head is not one of the things you see.
What does it like to see the world and simultaneously notice that your head is
not appearing in it.
See if that does anything to your sense of awareness.
Harding used to say that where his head was supposed to be,
it was just the world.
See if you can be mindful of that
in each moment
and now and gently close your eyes
and pay attention to this feeling
that you might have,
that you are now inside your head.
Your attention is in something,
but again,
what you're calling your head,
the sensations you get from your skin,
the muscles in your face.
All of that is appearing in consciousness.
That which is aware is not inside of something.
Everything is in it.
See if you can feel that.
Open your eyes again
and ask yourself what has changed?
Is there a sense that the world comes rushing in?
Yeah,
the space just cut bigger.
He might play with this opening and closing your eyes periodically.
Is there really a change?
Does it change in the contents of consciousness?
Clearly
there are things you can see with your eyes open that you can't with your eyes
closed,
but you still have a visual field in both cases.
Yeah.
When you close your eyes,
your visual field doesn't disappear.
Yeah.
All of this changing or the contents of consciousness
and more and more as we proceed in this practice,
we went to be looking to see if the feeling that consciousness has a center,
that there's a meditator in the middle of each moment of meditation,
I think or have thoughts.
His seer of sites here of sounds
we'll be looking into that
have feeling that awareness emanates from a single point inside the head
and in some ways this is even easier to do with eyes open because we use vision
to define ourselves in opposition to our environment more than we do with the
other senses.
There's a clear feeling that most of us have most of the time that we are behind
our face looking out at the world through our eyes.
But as you look out at the world in this moment,
see if that feeling is true.
You might look
to see if there's any evidence because you are behind your face
at this moment
and the moment you notice you're lost in thought.
Okay,
come back to this exercise.
Keep paying attention very wide
with our eyes open or closed.
Have you seen if this feeling of being inside the head
survive scrutiny
in the last minute of this session?
Just give up all efforts
and notice whatever appears on its own.
Well today I introduced a slightly different exercise
and there'll be some more of that coming from time to time.
This is good to use this growing facility with mindfulness to engage kind of
structured analysis of experience.
You can definitely precipitate certain insights by doing something a little more
directed than just noticing whatever happens to arise
and if you're interested you might get that book I mentioned on having no head
by Douglas Harding because he in a way that was quite unique to him,
developed analogies and exercises that can provoke an insight into the illusory
penis of subject object perception.
It's not to say that consciousness is neurons in the brain.
It's not making any claims about your mind being coterminous with the rest of
the physical world.
What Harding was doing was showing that this sense of being inside the head from
the side of experience changes when you actually look to see if it's true and as
you play with that exercise,
you might find that a very expansive and centerless sense of what awareness is
can emerge in place of this feeling that you would otherwise call I.
Okay,
well hopefully that gives you a sense of what I'm doing with awakened.
Of course,
again,
this is an ongoing project for me and as I add content to the course,
I'll be attempting to synthesize everything I've discovered in my own practice
and in philosophy and science generally.
That seems helpful for increasing our understanding of our own minds.
Of course,
many of these things have been discussed by philosophers and contemporary those
for thousands of years,
but they can now be viewed in a 21st century context.
So unlike my own podcast,
which deals with politics and recent developments in science and a host of
topical and controversial issues,
the waking of course is really a chance for me to talk about the most important
things I've ever learned.
So if you're interested in practicing meditation with me and engaging in
philosophical and scientific considerations about the nature of mind,
you can check it out@wakingup.com and thank you,
Tim,
for inviting me on your podcast.
Your audience should know that I consider myself not only a friend of yours,
but I'm also one of your true fans because yours is one of the podcasts that I
regularly listen to.
In fact,
with some regularity,
I steal your,
I discovered Eric Weinstein on your podcast and he and I now have done a few
together.
I found will macaskill here along with the inimitable Jocko Willink.
Um,
I think there may be a few others and all those guys became not only podcast
guests but friends as well.
So apart from being grateful that turned my life.
Tim,
I am hugely benefiting from what you were doing in the world.
So keep it up my friend and thanks again for introducing me to your audience.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends,
for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour workweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and you'll get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
My answer is inevitably athletic Greens.
It is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it to the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole food meals throughout the rest of the
day.
If you want to give athletic Greens and try,
they are offering a free 20 count travel pack for first time users.
I always travel with at least three or four of these.
This represents a $100 value,
so if you by Athletic Greens,
you get an extra $100 in free product,
so check it out.
athleticgreens.com/tim again,
that's athletic greens.com/tim for your free travel pack with any purchase.
This episode is brought to you by legal zoom,
which more than 2 million Americans have used to help start their businesses.
Past guests even such as wordpress,
the developer,
CEO of Automattic,
Matt Mullenweg now valued at more than a billion dollars of use.
Legal Zoom to help with their business needs.
Specifically in his case to form his company buds.
Legal Zoom isn't just for launching your business.
There are services include everything from helping you to manage changing tax
laws,
reviewing contracts,
creating Ndas,
nondisclosure agreements,
important stuff,
handling lease agreements and assisting with really other legal challenge,
hurdle,
inconvenience that typically takes time and effort away from running your
business.
The best part is that you won't get charged by the hour because legal zoom isn't
a law firms.
They won't be running the clock up and spinning circles just to raise your bill.
Instead,
they just ask you to pay one low upfront price for whatever it is that you're
looking to get a card style.
So visit legal zoom.com or check out their business section for all your
services.
And if you want special savings,
that's the terminology and copy that they suggest.
I don't know what the special savings is folks,
but it's titillating.
Do you want special savings?
Enter Promo Code Tim Tim at checkout capital t,
lowercase.
I am again,
take a beat legal zoom.com and enter Promo code.
Tim.